[Musique]
et
penser que celle de la famille ont des
comptes à viry il ya eu 14 fréquences
donc du génome de ce virus qui ont été
faites à partir de prélèvements faits
sur les bassins est donc on peut voir en
fait en train avant ce qu'on appelle un
arbre phylogénétique quelle est la
dhimmitude entre les séquences de ce
virus et des couronnes à viège connue et
dont il est génétiquement le virus
connus le plus muller à ce virus et le
sera donc le teint drôme respiratoire
aigu sévère qui avaient créé une énorme
et tout déni en 2003 2004 en chine mais
aussi il y avait beaucoup de cas au
canada et c'est donc le fras on continue
à circuler probablement sur certaines
formes chez des animaux
donc c'est probablement que le virus
qu'on voit maintenant à évoluer à partir
d'un virus qui était similaire phrase ou
qui était un ancêtre de ce que nous on a
connu comme étant le traces
donc ça veut dire que j'ai une petite
m'enfin c'est comme un arbre
généalogique quoi c'est un cousin le
cousin le plus proche du coronavirus que
l'on voit actuellement c'est le sable ou
le sras qui s'est transmis initialement
d'un animal à un homme est ensuite
c'était vraiment quasiment plus de la
transmission d'homme à homme est en tout
cas toutes les tout déni qu'on a connu
et c'est vraiment dur très très grande
majorité à de la transmission
interhumaine donc pour l'instant on est
pas capable de dire ça pour le nouveau
virus pour l'instant effectivement les
autorités chinoises ont trouvé des cas
pour lesquels ils ont été capables de
retracer une exposition à un autre cas
est donc on est maintenant qu'il faut à
certains du fait que le virus est
capable de transmettre entre les humains
mais on ne sait pas c'est pour l'instant
le nombre de cas qu'on a observée est
due essentiellement à la transmission
entre humains ou un mélange de
transmission entre humains et de
d'exposition le le marché de one a été
fermée qui en continu avoir beaucoup de
cas plus on continue à avoir des cas
plus pour moi cette suggère qu'il doit y
avoir de la transmission d'homme à homme
que la source originelle a été fermé
pour le taux de mortalité je pense qu'il
est encore trop tôt pour savoir s'il va
être de l'ordre de celui du trafic
étaient 10% quand même assez élevé c'est
clair que c'est quand même assez sévère
puisque des personnes peuvent en mourir
mais il est aussi hd clair qu' il ya
beaucoup de présentation assez modérée
on va dire que j'ai eu ce qui n'était
pas le cas pour le phare pour le ca on
est à peu près sûr que je veux pas être
très grande majorité des cas était
tellement sévère que ça n'était demos
catalysation là ça n'a pas l'air d'être
le cas
c'est plutôt une bonne nouvelle mais ça
veut aussi dire que il va être plus
difficile de détecter ces cas ci les
cages qui sont moins sévères transmettre
autant que les autres alors le fait
qu'on n'arrive pas à les détecter c'est
un problème parce que j'avais peur que
il va y avoir beaucoup de transmissions
qui va avoir lieu dans la communauté
sans qu'on arrive vraiment à l'identique
semblerait qu' il ya eu initialement
quelques dizaines de cas puis une
quarantaine et puis d'un coup les
chiffres en bike de 41 198 tout je ne
sais quoi donc on a l'impression que
d'un coup d'aile beaucoup de nouveaux
cas en fait c'est pas ça qui s'est
produit ce qui s'est produit c'est que
les autorités locales en changer la
définition de cas et donc ils ont
rétrospectivement reclassifier des
personnes qui n'étaient pas des cas mais
qu'ils étaient des personnes qui avaient
présenté des symptômes au début de
l'épisode i donc on défendre aujourd'hui
dans les rues de la cité comme étant des
cafés aussi tout à fait typique au début
d'une épidémie de commencer par ne voir
que les cavs très sévère qu'éthiquement
au tout début de l'épidémie aura
toujours mon voir que le haut de
l'iceberg discipline est là
vraisemblablement beaucoup de bien à
roanne
clairement c'est un endroit qui est très
connectée nationalement et
internationalement
donc il risque d'y avoir des
exportations de casse qui est ce qu'on a
vu donc j'étais trois quatre ou cinq
moment peut-être qu'à qui avaient tous
voyagé à vous
et qui ont été exportés maintenant ce
qui n'est pas clair
c est ce que c'est qu'un ont la capacité
ensuite de générer des épidémies dans
les pays où ils exportent que la malade
et ça encore une fois ça revient à poser
cette question de d'accord ce virus est
capable de se transmettre d'homme à
homme
mais est ce que cette capacité est
grande ou est qu'elle est limitée
e
[Musique]